somewhere in your body your immune
system just quietly killed one of your
own cells stopping it from becoming
cancer and saving your life it does that
all the time
the vast majority of cancer cells you
develop will be killed without you ever
noticing which is an incredibly hard job
because of what cancer cells are
parts of yourself that start to behave
as individuals even if it hurts you what
is cancer and how does your body kill it
all the time
[Music]
cancer is when corrupted cells multiply
uncontrollably
it could emerge from basically every
type of cell in your body so there's not
just a single type of cancer but
hundreds some grow slowly others are
aggressive some can be treated
effectively others are deadly in a sense
a cell that becomes cancer turns into
something ancient than something new
over billions of years Evolution has
molded cells to survive and thrive in a
hostile environment fighting for space
and resources until a new and exciting
way of life emerged cooperation a
division of labor that allowed cells to
specialize and become more successful
together
but cooperation requires sacrifices
for a multicellular being to stay
healthy the well-being of the collective
has to matter more than the survival of
the individual cell
cancer cells stop being part of the
collective and become individuals again
your body can handle a few Rogue cells
but some cancer cells divide again and
again becoming a sort of new organism
within you taking resources you need to
survive competing for the space you
inhabit destroying the organs they were
part of in the process
despite the harm they cause cancer cells
are not evil they don't want to hurt you
they don't want anything
cells are protein robots that just
follow their programming which
unfortunately has been corrupted
the soul of the cell
in a nutshell your cells have a nucleus
filled with DNA it consists of genes
instructions for how to build proteins
and when to make each one these building
instructions are copied and transferred
to ribosomes where they're used to make
proteins what kind of proteins your
cells make determine what they can do
the important thing here is that a
corrupt Gene means you get a corrupt
protein which will get important later
your DNA gets a tiny bit corrupted it
mutates tens of thousands of times each
day most of the time without any special
cause just by being alive
almost all of these mutations are fixed
very quickly or are not problematic
still over time as your sales make
copies of themselves damage is
accumulating imagine having to make
copies from copies from copies for
decades maybe one day a hair got on the
scanner or a corner got Freight each new
mistake becomes part of the new copies
and all the copies that follow
you can increase DNA damage by doing
things like smoking drinking alcohol by
being obese breathing in asbestos by not
using sunscreen or Contracting a virus
like HPV but the simplest way to damage
DNA and get cancer is to be alive long
enough
for many cancer cases there is no cause
other than bad luck the damage that
leads to cancer
we are simplifying but roughly there are
three categories of genes that need to
be corrupted so cancer can arise the
first key mutation is in the
appropriately named tumor suppressor
genes or tsgs these genes are a bunch of
things for one they produce control
mechanisms that continuously scan your
DNA for mistakes and copying errors and
fix them right away and then they keep
normal cells from multiplying recklessly
if tsgs become damaged your cells
basically forget how to repair
themselves and can reproduce unchecked
the second crucial mutation can happen
in your oncogenes when oncogenes are
turned on the cell is told to multiply
rapidly
they were super active when you were
inside your mother's womb to turn a
single original cell into trillions in
months it needs to divide and grow
rapidly these rapid growth genes are
turned off when there's enough of you
when your oncogenes get corrupted they
basically turn on again
the third crucial mutation is in your
cell's suicide switch
most cells are constantly recycled and
refreshed when cells amass too much
damage they usually notice and special
genes trigger a controlled suicide
called apoptosis
if the genes that control this process
get damaged cells are free to live on
despite being dangerously corrupted so
if a cell becomes unable to fix the
mistakes in its genetic code loses the
ability to destroy itself when it
notices the damage and begins to grow
rapidly without restraint it turns into
a young cancer cell
these cells have to be killed as quickly
as possible while they are bad at this
stage they are still pretty weak and
easy to kill
but if they continue to mutate and
increase in number they can learn to
avoid your defenses and become a real
threat at any moment of your life your
immune system is hunting these cells but
how do you identify and kill corrupted
cells that seem indistinguishable from
healthy ones
how to find cancer
well here we come back to the proteins
your cells produce and the story they
tell so if for example your oncogene
switch back on they make oncogene
proteins your immune system knows that
they should not be present if you're an
adult so to know which cells are corrupt
and which are healthy your immune system
needs to know what proteins they're
making inside to solve this Evolution
came up with MHC class 1 molecules a
sort of display window that makes cells
transparent cells constantly take little
samples of the proteins they make and
put them into thousands of these MHC
molecules to Showcase what they're doing
the selection is constantly refreshed
always giving an up-to-date picture
there's a whole library of proteins that
are highly dangerous and should not be
made by healthy cells and your immune
system has them all on file it has
billions of specialized cells called t
cells made to recognize specific
proteins if a T Cell sees a forbidden
protein in an MHC display window it
knows that the cell is corrupted and
kills it immediately
but there's a floor in this system what
if a cancer cell mutates and finds a way
to circumvent this process all it needs
to do is to stop making MHC class 1
molecules and boom it's invisible
without display Windows the immune
system is blind and can't identify
cancer anymore
fortunately Evolution found an ingenious
solution the natural killer cell a judge
jury and executioner the Killer
at this very second hundreds of millions
of natural killer cells are patrolling
your body looking for cells that have
already turned into cancer or are
corrupted by a virus natural killer
cells go from cell to cell to check for
one thing
does a cell have MHC class 1 molecules
does it have a display window and is it
doing its duty of showing off what's
going on inside itself this is so
amazing because it covers all of your
bases while T cells look for the
presence of the unexpected something
that should not be here natural killer
cells look for the absence of the
expected the absence of something that
should be here the logic is if a cell
does not have display Windows it wants
to hide something and a cell that hides
something must be killed
and what makes the natural killer cell
even more metal is that it's always in
Murder mode it patrols your body
checking cell after cell with the
intention of killing it your healthy
cells have to convince it that they
should not die today and a way to do
that is to have MHC class 1 molecules
so in summary almost all young cancer
cells you will ever develop in your life
will be killed by your immune system
okay but if your body is this prepared
why do we still get cancer well
sometimes cancer cells mutate more and
get much better at fighting back
cancer is a story of an arms race an
arms race that we will win eventually
maybe with the help of natural killer
cells right now a number of therapies
are beginning to show amazing promise
from cancer fighting vaccines to
engineered T cells and even natural
killer cells we'll look at these
Therapies in future videos so the war is
not one yet but we are on to cancer and
eventually it will be eliminated once
and for all maybe sooner than we think
this video was made possible in part by
direct viewer support and in part
through a grant by Gates Ventures thanks
a lot for their support and stay tuned
for part two
please check out our source document for
more background and in-depth information
[Music]